the Joe Rogan experience which is uh
Twitter said we will now be removing
tweets if you contradict official
authoritative health sources so that's
just what I did
Surgeon General's lying CDC's line waho
is lying come at me do you think they're
lying yes but what why do you think
they're lying like give me a specific
example why you feel like they're lying
well for example you saw this
interaction with the was it Hong Kong TV
asking about the wh Oh about yeah that
was insane well explain that because
it's [ __ ] and saying it was insane to
watch first of all he pretended the the
head of the w-h-o pretended he didn't
hear them and then he had them say it
again first of all he moves like yes you
can see his hand yes I go to cut off the
connection he hung on he said I couldn't
hear she's okay I'll repeat the question
he's like no let's go on to the next one
well why would he want to go in to the
next one if he didn't hear it come on
yeah I don't even have here's the point
we are so afraid explain what he did to
people that don't know because people
are listening here and there he was
asked about the Taiwanese response yes
to the Cova tepid emic and he didn't
want to say Taiwan because China claims
that Taiwan is part of China and because
China exercises so much influence over
the whu-oh he wanted to say some very
general thing which is like I think all
provinces of China have been doing an
excellent yeah that's a different
country Taiwan because there's a dispute
so what do you think China's most
interested in China PTIN the People's
Republic of China the Communist China
Communist Chinese want no recognition of
their existing something called Taiwan
and why does the World Health
Organization give in to that well how do
how do different nations get control of
things you know we have influence at the
UN and we've caused the UN to do things
that are America centric you know other
countries have influence and you do this
by being on particular committees
rotating directorships who pays
the cost I don't know how the w-h-o
seems to be so enmeshed with China and I
don't want to opine about these things
because I want to keep my voice right
but it spoke volumes to watch that guy
do that and do that little dance try to
avoid saying time while my entire life
looks like that interview I mean I hate
to say it this way but my relationship
with Authority and my big critique is is
that this is the generic expectation
across almost all institutions now they
are all serving bizarre goals because
growth is what gave us our independence
and when we became less innovative and
we or the innovations dried up and we
couldn't grow our way into new things
the number of people who could use their
middle finger effectively and say I'm
steering this at this organization to do
the right thing and then this is my bet
and we're going to go forward those
people as a class were removed if you
think about like what do you do with
Churchill when there isn't a world war
two to win it's very uncomfortable like
what would you open a drycleaner we
don't know you have you have special
people who really only shine when
there's an emergency there's a guy named
Jay Prakash and Orion in India was very
important he was one of the sort of
founding fathers of modern India and
after India of Indian independence was
achieved lots of the people who had been
founding fathers went to the next phase
where they became like they enriched
themselves they did standard political
things to getting power in the system he
was the one guy who sort of stayed true
to the revolutionary spirit and
bizarrely when Indira Gandhi created a
state of emergency which was a disaster
in India the people said well who can we
turn to in a dark time and oddly I guess
Prakash means light so there was this
phrase like in the darkness there is one
light Jai Prakash Jaya Prakash Jaya
Prakash they turned to the one guy who
had become the patron saint of lost
causes because he never broke faith with
the revolutionary spirit and he's get he
gets called up once but he's incredibly
important because everybody knows in a
dark
time who they can trust right that's a
very important parallel to where we are
now who are the break glass in case of
emergency people yeah when you when you
watch the people that are talking in
these presidential addresses there's
none of those I don't see any break
glass I mean this foul Qi guy is
obviously an expert in diseases and he's
a doctor and he's trying to do his best
to lay out the ground rules of what we
need to do and what this looks like over
the next couple of months but but it's
like Jocko willing you know like Jocko
is not telling you don't worry you don't
have to change your routine you can get
up at 9:30 just do a little bit just a
little bit there's like does the plinth
equals freedom I'm up at 4:30 what are
you doing in bed it's time for
discipline well because he's a military
guy and military people don't have any
room for [ __ ] military people love
no right people like seals they don't
have any room for fluff wealth because
you have to be able to perform well ok
so then in that situation so [ __ ] your
feelings get up at 4:30 that's that's
how they feel that's what I'm trying so
those you can just do a little bit and
that's great that's great you guys are
enforcing mediocrity congrats and that's
what I'm trying to get at which is yeah
we have a situation where we know if you
have two trainers and one of them is
doing that don't worry and the other
want to say not gonna lie to you
you're gonna be sore you're gonna be
miserable this isn't going to be fun
which do you choose
some people will go with the former yeah
they like to stay fat it's a lot of that
out there
ok mediocrity is a very comforting thing
I hear you yeah it's [ __ ] look it's
hard
[Applause]